in the jewish tradition it is common not
to reveal the name until the bris you
know you don't want to jinx it basically
so we had to come up with a nickname and
we came up with button it means peanut
it's a peanut it works good
i obviously was hoping for a girl this
time but i love being a boy mom so i was
not disappointed at all and i was happy
that it's another boy also
that means we have an opening for
another try
and i think i won four in total
the only way i would consider four kids
is if by some miracle the next time we
try it's twins
you seem excited
me excited i know it's weird alex
showing emotion with emotion i'm happy
is any part of you nervous no you're so
full
no part of you is nervous about having
two under two
no oh my god you're lying i'm not lying
i don't know if it's an israeli state of
mind but alex is just like yeah cool
it's fine we've got this for now nothing
is difficult because it's not really
parenting yet it's just like
you know they're small
oh i think i have to pee again no no
but i don't know because maybe it's just
him on the side a little bit ahead of
the time not when you're already losing
every time it's the same i can hold that
i can hold it stop now
i think i should really get a diaper
listen the sneeze and the cough is so
real
wow especially at night
so you pee all over me at night or what
why do you think i'm washing the sheets
every day
no it wasn't no oh my god for real no
that's it i'm staying only on my side
from now on i'm not even getting near
your side
i'm not proper during pregnancy
listen the body is going through things
that one cannot help
and he
has to deal with it if i make a toot i
make a tooth like it is what it is in
hospitals i saw a lot
just saying i did see herself
[Music]
you